сама це рішення в принципі юридично
не має під собою підстави, оскільки
апелює норми міжнародного права а
керуючись якими
приймати рішення щодо
сусідньої країни і в цьому сенсі
ніхто не наділяв її такими повноваженнями
давати такого роду оцінку фактам
юридичну оцінку своїх рішень тем
більше що там є ще одне відсилання до
тому що ось цей олійник депутат не
має можливості скористатися
тягати правом на звернення до суду
місце громадянство тобто в Україні
мене виникає образу чому
як він буде а капелюшок рішення не як ви
вважатимете це рішення рівно і
заповіту по я виходжу давай визначення
цьому рішенню як пропагандисти
участі таких осіб як азаров янукович
захарченко і так далі, що означає точно
це необхідно було для танці перш ніж
пропагандистський ефект можливо я не
виключаю що хтось вселив цим людям
що таке рішення російського суду
допоможе їм все плече
тобто віра піску суді з прав
людину захищає свої інтереси ось
вказані вище особи які захочуть
вийти з антонів списків там зняти
заморожування з майна їх
підставі юридичних рішень у самій
україні яке накладено або арешту та
або інші означає юридично значущі
якісь дії
до звернення то її чоловік може
бути вони намагаються з цього рішення
одержати ось цю вигоду я це не випадково
на безглузді рішення подібного роду не
варто реагувати і найголовніше
мавпи що не повторювати нічого
подібного
велика спокуса у української влади
відповісти чимось подібним розумієте
сказати ну так ми зараз взагалі
делегуємо результат з вересневих виборів
державні будинок у російській
федерації теж якийсь депутат панама
в якій зараз проживає в Києві
наприклад вийшли будуть держдума не будете
допущені візьме і подасть щось
таке але це ви знаєте найбільш не вмію що
можна зробити мені здається що саме
виграє той хто дотримується не
тільки духу та літери норм дроту і в тому
числі міжнародного права та той хто
виглядає розумніше означає даючи собі право
посміятися з ідіотизму тягати свого
сусіда